this morning we are bringing you a
special segment from the CBS News series
down-to-earth it is our partnership with
Facebook watch that showcases unique
storytelling the United Nations is
urging people to eat less meat it says
animal agriculture is a leading cause of
greenhouse gases and eating less meat
could free up millions of acres of land
where you can plant trees to clean the
air Seth stone who travel to high-tech
laboratories in Tel Aviv to see how
slaughter free meat is made it's real
steak and real chicken but no animals
were hurt so-called clean meat is
created out of cells from farm animal
tissues and more than likely it's coming
to a table near you
this truly qualifies as experimenting in
the kitchen not the recipe but the steak
itself we had to sign a waiver just to
try it
you've worked hard for that bite Alif
farm CEO DDA to be explained how they're
growing steak from the stem cells of
cows at this laboratory near Tel Aviv we
can produce meat more efficiently in a
way which is more ethical more
sustainable and healthier
environmentalists say we should be
eating less meat according to the United
Nations farming animals is one of the
most dangerous sources of greenhouse
gases and water pollution right now most
of the agriculture is there to feed the
animals at el margul eat is a
billionaire investor in so-called food
technology including what he calls clean
meat made in the lab we need to change
the way agriculture and food are being
produced humans cannot continue to eat
the way we are today
no because the planet will not sustain
it the beauty would sell this meat is
that once you've established the sell
back you don't need the chicken anymore
so theoretically one chicken can feed
the world at super meat CEO IDO severe
explained how they extract stem cells
from chickens those stem cells can
become any type of cell so by tweaking
the mix of proteins and amino acids they
can direct them to become whatever they
need muscle fat or connective tissue
inside it looks very similar to a sort
of artificial womb and severe ads
they'll be able to produce exact
the cuts of meat desired a vegan himself
severe thinks there's also potential for
consumers who object to killing an
animal these are very delicate borscht
one of the many hurdles is the sci-fi
aspect of all of this and severe hopes
Minds will be changed at the table with
the first lab produced meat
likely served in restaurants within a
few years and as to our taste of the
future tastes like chicken
it was surprisingly normal no one can
seem to agree on a turn I here clean
meat I hear cultured meat or sell based
meat I think that once it's it's vastly
produced and distributed it will just be
cold meat that's what CBS this morning
Seth Doane Tel Aviv was it just me or
did Seth take a long time to answer
freaky meat and it is not for me very
small portion it this could be the
future okay sure sixty plants people we
could use eat plants we don't need to
eat me you know you can survive on an
all plan diet is possible there is
enough protein I've heard I've heard
that rumor
all right well to see more of sets
down-to-earth report go to our website
CBS this morning calm